- Welcome back to Understanding Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous and I'm the Technical Director for
Education at IBM Quantum.
This is the seventh lesson of the series and in this lesson we'll discuss the phase estimation problem and how we can solve it
with a quantum computer.
We'll then apply phase estimation to the problem of integer factorization, which we discussed in the previous lesson.
What we'll obtain is Shor's algorithm, which allows integers to be
factorized at polynomial cost or in polynomial time if we prefer
to think in terms of the time required rather than the number of
elementary operations we need.
This is the crown jewel of
quantum algorithms in some sense, and while factorized large integers
may have limited utility for most people, it remains one of the most
compelling pieces of evidence that we have for the hypothesis that quantum computers will
offer striking advantages
over classical computers. Here's an overview of the lesson.
We'll start with a definition of the phase estimation problem itself, and then we'll discuss a method for solving this problem
with a quantum computer.
We'll take it one step at a time, beginning with what you can
think of as a kind of a warmup.
In the phase estimation problem, the goal is to approximate
a certain real number and in this warmup part
we'll see how we can get
a very low precision
approximation to this number.
This isn't going to be
good enough for factoring when we apply our solution to
the phase estimation problem to integer factorization,
we're actually going to need a pretty high precision approximation, but it's nevertheless useful to begin with this sort of a warmup
just to get a sense for
how the whole thing works.
We'll then discuss the issue of how we can get more precision, and this will lead very
naturally to an operation known as the Quantum Fourier transform.
We'll see exactly what this operation is and how it can be implemented
with a quantum circuit.
And once we have it, we'll be able to apply
it to phase estimation to come up with a general procedure for solving the problem
with very high precision.
Then in the last part of the lesson, we'll see how a solution to
the phase estimation problem allows us to factor integers efficiently.
And specifically what we'll get is Shor's algorithm for
integer factorization, or at least something that's equivalent to Shor's algorithm.
The way that this works is that we basically give
ourselves a stepping stone, which is yet another problem called the order finding problem.
And in particular we'll see how we can solve the order finding problem using the phase estimation procedure and then we'll see how
we can factor integers
by solving the order finding problem. We're going to begin with a special case of a theorem called the Spectral theorem,
and specifically we're going to focus on what the theorem tells
us for unitary matrices.
The spectral theorem is
a very important theorem from linear algebra and
functional analysis.
It tells us something interesting about how certain linear mappings can be expressed in a certain form, it's often called a
spectral decomposition,
that's useful for many reasons.
And like I said, we're going to focus on what this theorem tells
us for unitary matrices.
The spectral theorem is
more general than this. It doesn't work for all matrices, but it does work for a class of matrices
called normal matrices, which include all unitary matrices as well as some matrices
that aren't unitary.
But just to keep things simple, we'll restrict our attention
to unitary matrices for now because that's all we need for
the purposes of this lesson.
Here's a statement of the spectral theorem just for unitary matrices.
Suppose that U is an
N by N unitary matrix.
What the theorem says
is that there must exist an orthonormal basis of
vectors, psi one through psi N,
along with N complex numbers
Lambda one through Lambda N, all lying on the complex unit circle so that U can be expressed
as we have in this equation.
This is called a spectral
decomposition of U, as I've already mentioned, and it can be very convenient to know that U can be written in this way.
It can sometimes be convenient to have these vectors and these numbers when we're working with
a particular unitary matrix U, and it can also be very
useful simply to know
that such an expression is always possible as a way of proving certain things about unitary matrices for instance.
In this statement of the theorem, each of these numbers,
Lambda one through lambda N, is written in a particular way
as E to the power two pi I times theta where each of the thetas
theta one through theta N is a real number, and
we'll come back to this way
of writing each of these
numbers in just a little bit.
An important thing to notice
about these vectors and numbers is that each vector psi
K must be an eigenvector of the matrix U with
corresponding eigenvalue lambda K.
Which means that if we
multiply psi K by U, what we get is lambda K times psi K.
So what U does to each of these vectors is simply to multiply it by the corresponding number lambda K.
In general for some arbitrary vector, this won't be how U works, but eigenvectors are special.
And what the theorem tells us is that there is in fact
an ortho normal basis of these eigenvectors.
This equation down here by the way, follows from the expression that we have for U from the theorem, together with the fact that
the vectors are orthonormal.
If you multiply the
expression of U to any psi K and use the orthonormality of the vectors, you'll get a sum in which
all of the terms are zero
except for one of them, and the one term that we're
left with looks like this.
Now we can define the
phase estimation problem.
The problem is a little
bit unusual as we'll see.
We're given two things. First, we're given the description of a unitary quantum circuit,
that acts on N qubits
for some choice of N, and when we say that this
is a unitary circuit,
we just mean that all of
the gates are unitary, so there are no measurements
in this circuit.
Second, we're given an N Qubit state psi, and that's the unusual part.
We actually have a quantum
state input for this problem, and it's a single copy of this state.
For all the other computational problems we've talked about in this series, the input has been classical, either in the form of a string
of bits or as a black box.
And that's not surprising because the computational
problems that we encounter in our daily lives tend to be classical,
'cause those are the
problems we care most about.
The way that you can
think about this problem is that it's something that appears or is likely to appear as a sub problem.
And the phase estimation procedure we'll eventually come up with is something that we
generally use as a sub-routine
inside of some larger computation, presumably one for a classical
problem that we care about.
Now, this is going to be a promise problem and the state psi isn't
just any old quantum state.
We're promised that psi is an eigenvector of whatever unitary operation U it is that the given circuit describes.
And the goal is to find or
approximate the eigenvalue that corresponds to the eigenvector psi.
Let's state the problem a
little bit more precisely.
The input consists of a unitary
quantum circuit on N qubits, which can be encoded as a string of bits
using whatever method we prefer for encoding quantum circuit descriptions, along with an N Qubit state psi.
We can call the circuit whatever we want, but what really matters in terms of the statement of this problem is the unitary operation itself
that's performed when the circuit is run, and that unitary operation
is described by the Matrix U.
But we're not given U as a matrix, we're just given the description of a quantum circuit that implements U.
The promise, as I've already stated, is that psi is an eigenvector of U.
So if we ran our circuit on psi, we'd get psi coming out multiplied by whatever the eigenvalue is,
which would be a global
phase in that situation.
And finally, the output of the problem is an approximation to the eigenvalue corresponding to psi, and specifically we're looking for
an approximation to the real number theta, between zero and one, including
zero, but not including one
that satisfies the equation
that we have on the screen.
To explain this way of
parameterizing the eigenvalue corresponding to pis, and also to clarify what we mean by an approximation,
let's draw a picture of
the complex unit circle.
We can put the numbers one, I,
negative one, and negative I in their usual places and we can consider
some arbitrary point on the
circle parameterized by theta as we have in the problem statement.
This is the point we
get if we start at one and rotate by an angle of
two times pi times theta, so the angle isn't
theta, it's two pi theta,
and another way of thinking about it is that if we start at one and we travel a distance of two pi theta on the circle itself,
we'll get to our point, E to
the two times pi times theta.
Every point in the complex unit circle can be represented in this way
for a unique choice of theta.
And that's because we go
all the way around circle as theta goes from zero to one, and if we went all the
way to theta equals one,
we'd be back where we
started at theta equals zero, so that's why we include zero, but we don't include one.
Just to make sure that each
point on the complex unit circle corresponds to a unique value of theta in the range that we're considering.
There are various ways
that we could imagine approximating a particular value of theta, but the way that we'll do it is to approximate theta with a fraction,
where the denominator
is two to the power M for some choice of a positive integer M, and the numerator is an integer y
between zero and two to the M minus one.
You can think about this as an mbit approximation to theta if you wish, and we could write this
number in binary notation
where we have a binary point followed by the binary
representation of Y.
I say binary point by the
way rather than decimal point because decimal means base 10 and I'm talking about base two
here, but it's the same idea.
But in any case we can
also just think about it as a fraction like it
appears on the screen.
And to be clear, when we think about
approximations in this context, it should be understood
that values of theta
near zero and values of theta near one are in fact close together.
So for example, if theta is equal to 0.99 and we approximate this value
of theta by the value zero,
then that's a pretty good approximation in the sense that it's
within one of our hundred of the actual value, when
we wrap around the circle
and go back to zero when we get to one.
The term modular one is sometimes used to describe the situation, where we're essentially
equating theta equals one with theta equals zero.
The point is that we really care about the location of the point
E to the two pi I theta on the unit circle,
and thinking about this
way of approximating theta makes sense when we have that aim in mind.
The problem statement itself,
as it appears on the screen, isn't specific about how good the approximation to theta needs to be,
but that's something that we can fine tune depending upon our needs.
In some situations we might be satisfied with a low precision
approximation to theta, and in other situations we might demand
a very high precision approximation, and the problem statement itself
can be refined accordingly.
Next we'll see how we can solve
the phase estimation problem with a quantum computer and
we'll start with a warmup.
This won't be our final
solution to the problem.
What we'll do is to make use of the phase kickback phenomenon to try to learn something
about the eigenvalue corresponding to a given eigenvector.
Recall that in the
phase estimation problem we're given the description
of a unitary quantum circuit for some operation U,
and what we do first is to
use this circuit description to create a new circuit that implements a controlled U operation like
is pictured on the screen.
This is pretty simple to do. What we can do is to add a control Qubit, which is pictured on
the top in this diagram
and use this new control
Qubit as a control for every single gate that
appears in our circuit.
So all of the gates are applied if this control Qubit is set to one, and none of them is applied if the control Qubit is set to zero,
That means that we're going
to need a controlled version of every gate that
appears in the circuit U, but we don't need to think
about these new controlled gates
as single gates if we don't want to. They could be implemented
as small circuits made out of gates from whatever gates set
we've chosen to use. And once we have a
controlled version of U, we can consider running this circuit,
where we first put the control Qubit into a superposition of zero and one, apply the controlled U gate to the eigenvector side that we're given,
and then apply a Hadamard gate
to the control and measure.
We'll see why it makes sense to do this as we go through the analysis, but even before we get to the details, we can immediately see a similarity
with Deutsche's algorithm for instance, where we're applying a
couple of Hadamard gates and measuring as a way
of effectively probing
what it is that some given
operation is doing here.
It's a controlled unitary
rather than a query gate, but there are very similar ideas at play.
So let's see what the circuit does.
The initial state is the eigenvector psi, tensored with the zero
state for the control Qubit,
applying the first Hadamard gate transforms the state of the
top Qubit to a plus state and we can expand the entire
state as is shown right here.
We then apply the controlled U operation and what that does is to apply U to psi when the control Qubit is set to one,
but not when it's set to zero. So we get the state pi two
that's written on the screen.
We can simplify the state
using the fact that psi is an eigenvector of U with eigenvalue e to the two pi I theta.
So we get that eigenvalue multiplying the second
term, but not the first.
And we can simplify using the bilinearity
of the tensor product.
So what we have here is the
phase kickback phenomenon, but this time it's happening for some arbitrary eigenvector psi of some arbitrary unitary operation U,
s opposed to a not operation being applied to a minus
state more specifically.
So that's the state after the controlled U operation is applied.
By the way, it's worth
taking a moment to notice that the state of the bottom end Qubits is still the eigenvector psi.
Which is great because that
gives us the opportunity to use it again if we choose.
Then the second Hadamard gate is performed and here is the state that we get.
And I haven't shown all the
details of the derivation here, but if you apply the
Hadamard gate and simplify, this is what you should get.
So that's the state just
prior to the measurement.
So we can focus on this state to see what we can learn
about theta by measuring.
And if we measure the top
Qubit or the rightmost Qubit, these are the probabilities that we get for the two outcomes.
And here have used a
couple of basic formulas that relate sins and cosines
to complex exponentials to express these probabilities
in terms of sins and cosines.
Specifically, the probability to get zero is the cosine squared of pi times theta and the probability to get one
is the sin squared of the same angle. And this makes sense
because the sin squared plus the cosine squared of
any angle is equal to one.
So our probabilities
sum to one as we expect.
And here is a plot of these probabilities as a function of theta.
To be clear, this is a plot of
the probabilities themselves as opposed to a plot depicting a single probability
distribution for instance.
For example, if theta
is equal to one half, then the probability that
we get the outcome one which is drawn in purple is equal to one
while the probability
to get the outcome zero, which is drawn in blue, is zero.
On the other hand, if theta is equal to one
quarter or three quarters, then we have that each of the two outcomes is equally likely.
And of course for all choices of theta, the sum of the probabilities is equal to one as we've already observed.
So we don't learn exactly what
theta is from this procedure, but it does give us some
information about theta.
And if we imagine a situation in which we're promised
that theta is equal to zero or theta is equal to one half, this procedure will tell us
exactly which one of the
two possibilities it is.
So that's a simple way that we can use the phase kickback phenomenon to learn something about the eigenvalue.
So how can we learn more
about the eigenvalue?
Well, this is a situation in which we can let
ignorance be our guide.
Because there really aren't
too many things that we can do.
We don't know much of anything
about the eigenvector sin, and we also don't know
much about the operation U.
We have a circuit for U, but for all we know it's
a horrible, confusing mess that we won't be able to make
any sense of by examining it.
But one natural option is to run the circuit multiple times.
In particular, we could try to do exactly the same thing that we just did, except that instead of applying just a single controlled U operation,
we apply that operation twice. Or we could apply it any number of times, but let's start with twice
just to see what happens.
Well, it's actually pretty
simple what happens. By applying the controlled
U operation twice, we're effectively just
squaring the eigenvalue
because it'll get kicked into
the phase of the top Qubit two times rather than just once.
And so when we think about
the outcome probabilities as a function of theta, we're essentially just
doubling the frequency.
For each possible choice of theta, the outcome probabilities
are the same as they would be if we doubled theta and then
took the fractional part
to get a number between zero and one.
For example, if theta
is equal to one half, then the eigenvalue is negative one.
So by applying U twice we're effectively squaring the eigenvalue and the result is the same as it would be for theta equals zero.
Which is that the probability
for the outcome zero, pictured in blue, is equal to one, and the probability for the outcome one, pictured in purple, is equal to zero.
This is very simple, but we can in fact get
some additional information about theta by doing this.
For example, if we know in advance that either theta is equal to zero or theta equals one quarter, then this circuit will reveal to us
which of the two possibilities it is.
On the other hand, we can no longer distinguish the case that theta is equal to zero from the case that theta equals one half.
So this procedure isn't strictly better than the one from before when
we had a single control U gate but by also running this circuit
we can gain additional information.
It's not immediately clear
how the additional information we can get by iterating the controlled U operation multiple times
can be reconciled with
the information we get by performing it just once, and in fact there are multiple
ways we could proceed.
For instance, there's a technique called iterative phase estimation, which involves running circuits like the ones that we've seen,
along with some minor variations on them, to come up with an approximation to theta.
But I'm gonna describe
what could be called a more traditional approach, where we use a single quantum circuit that has multiple control qubits
that control different
numbers of iterations of the unitary operation U.
First I'll describe how this
works for two control qubits and then a bit later we'll generalize it to more than two control qubits.
Here's a quantum circuit
that uses two control qubits.
The top control Qubit
controls a single U operation while the second from top
Qubit controls two copies of U.
So what we're doing is combining the two circuits that we saw previously, in a way that makes use of the single copy
of the eigenvector psi that we have.
You'll notice however
that the Hadamard gates after the controlled U
operations have been removed and there are no measurements yet.
What we're going to do is to
see how this circuit works and then we'll figure
out what we should do with the top two qubits
in order to learn as much as possible about the value theta that
we're trying to approximate.
After the Hadamard gates performed, we had the state that's
shown on the screen.
And this is going to be a convenient way of writing the state to
see what happens next.
A zero and A one are bits, and if we think about the top two qubits as being a two Qubit register,
we're thinking about A zero, which corresponds to the top Qubit as being the lesser significant bit, and A one which corresponds
to the lower control Qubit
as being the more significant bit.
After the first controlled
U operation is performed, we obtain this state.
The classical state corresponding to the top control Qubit is a zero, so the result of the phase kickback
can be expressed in this way. Then after the second and
third controlled U operations
are performed, we obtain this state.
The idea is the same as for the first one, except this time we're applying the control U operation twice.
So we multiply A one by two in
the exponent to reflect this.
And now we can simplify this expression by thinking about the bits
A one and A zero together as an integer between zero and
three using binary notation.
That is when we think
about the two bit string, A one A zero, as the binary
encoding of an integer,
what we get is two
times A one plus A zero.
And the understanding is
that when we write Cat X, we're talking about X written as a binary string of length
too using binary notation.
So now let's focus on
these two control qubits to figure out what we
can learn about theta from them at this point.
The remaining N qubits are
still in the same state psi that we were originally given, which is really a wonderful
thing about this approach
because like I said before, we can use that state again if we want to gain even more
information about theta.
But for now, let's just think about what we can learn from
these two control qubits.
To help us to figure out how to proceed, let's imagine that we're promised that theta is equal to Y over four
for some integer y between zero and three.
In general, theta may not
be one of these four values, but this is a natural case to consider.
We saw in the original single control Qubit version of the procedure that if we were promised that theta is either zero or one half
the circuit would reveal which one it was. And we also noticed that in the version where we applied the
controlled U operation twice,
we could perfectly discriminate the case that theta equals zero from the case that theta
equals one quarter.
So we might hope that with our new circuit we can discriminate these four cases.
In essence, what we're
doing is that we're using the notion of a promise problem
to make the problem easier, so that we can see how to proceed.
And that's not a bad idea, in general. If you have a problem and you
don't know how to solve it, try making it easier.
If you can solve the easier problem, the insight you gain might be helpful in solving the more general problem.
And if you can't solve the easier problem, you're probably not ready
for the more general problem.
So keep on making it easier
until you can solve it.
Anyway, getting back to our problem, let's define a two Qubit state for each of the possible values of Y.
In other words, phi Y is equal to the state
shown on the top of the screen when theta is chosen
specifically to be Y over four.
And here are those four
states written out explicitly.
So just to reiterate, if
theta is equal to Y over four for Y being zero, one, two, or
three and we run our circuit,
we're going to be left with
one of these four states, whichever one corresponds
to the right value of Y.
And we just wanna figure
out which one it is.
And the question is, is this possible?
And the answer to that question is yes, because these four states are orthogonal.
If you compute the inner product
between any pair of them, you'll get zero.
And because they're orthogonal, they can be perfectly discriminated by a projective measurement.
And in particular we can
express such a measurement by defining one projection for each vector like we have here.
This always works, anytime
we have an orthonormal basis, and you can check this
against the definitions we saw in lesson three
for this specific case
if you're so inclined. So we conclude that it is
possible to accomplish our task,
which is to learn the value of Y from the state that's shown
on the top of the screen.
And if we'd like to do that
with a quantum circuit, we can proceed as I'll now explain.
First we can define a unitary matrix V whose columns are the four
vectors listed in order.
That matrix will have the action described on the bottom of the screen,
on the standard basis states,
and we can write down the matrix
to see what it looks like.
Because V maps each standard basis state, kappa Y to the vector phi Y, we have that by applying V dagger,
or in other words V inverse to phi Y will transform back the other way to the corresponding standard basis state.
So what we can do is to apply V dagger to whatever state we
obtained from our circuit.
And then if we perform a
standard basis measurement, we'll get the number Y
that we're looking for, expressed as a string
of length two in binary.
Before we go any further, let's talk a bit more
about the unitary matrix V.
This is a special matrix and
you may have seen it before.
It's the matrix associated
with a linear operation on four dimensional vectors known as the discrete Fourier transform.
To be more precise, the discrete Fourier transform can be defined for any
positive integer dimension, and we'll take a look at it
in general in a few moments.
And this is what it
looks like specifically when the dimension is equal to four.
We can think about the
discrete Fourier transform in different ways.
We can think about it purely abstractly as a linear mapping on vectors that can be represented by a matrix.
And we can also think about
it as a computational problem where we're given a vector, and we want to compute the result
of applying this linear mapping.
That turns out to be an incredibly important
computational problem, and there's a highly efficient algorithm for performing that computation
known as the fasts Fourier transform.
In fact, this is such an important problem in signal processing for example, that the fasts Fourier
transform is considered by many
to be one of the most important and consequential
algorithms ever discovered.
We can also think about the
discrete Fourier transform as a unitary quantum operation that can be applied to
a quantum state vector.
And when we think about it in that way, we call it the quantum Fourier
transform, or QFT for short.
Mathematically speaking, it's essentially the same thing as the discrete Fourier transform, but we call it the
quantum Fourier transform
just to clarify that it's an operation being applied to a quantum state vector.
So let's change the name of our matrix, from V to QFT four to reflect the fact
that the operation that we've come up with is in fact the quantum Fourier transform.
So here's the complete circuit for learning the value of Y when we're promised that
theta equals Y over four
for Y being zero, one, two, or three.
And just to make sure it's clear, we're applying the inverse of
the quantum Fourier transform, or in other words QFT four dagger
to map one of the four possible states back to the standard basis state, cat Y, so that we can recover Y by measuring.
So that's the circuit we
get from thinking about the promised version of the
phase estimation problem, where we're promised that theta
is zero, one quarter, one
half, or three quarters, but there's nothing that prevents us
from running this circuit for
an arbitrary value of theta.
And if we do that, here
are the probabilities for the four possible
outcomes that we obtain.
Each of the four possible
values for Y has its own color, and the plot tells us
what the probabilities are for each one as a function of theta.
So for instance, if theta
is equal to three quarters, we'll get the outcome
three with probability one,
well the probabilities for the other three outcomes are all zero as we already know from thinking about the promise version of the problem.
If theta is close to three quarters but not exactly three quarters, there will be some non-zero probability associated with the other outcomes,
but we'll still get the outcome
three with high probability.
So even though theta may
not be equal to Y over four, we can still think
about the outcome we get from the measurements divided by four
as being a guess or an
approximation for theta.
The guess may be wrong, but nevertheless it is
providing us with information.
And one thing that we
can learn from the plot is that best approximations always have the highest
probabilities associated with them.
When I say best approximation, I mean whatever value of Y over four is closest to the true value of theta,
in the modular one sense. The worst possible case is that theta is exactly halfway between
two values of Y over four.
For example, if theta is equal
to three eighths or 0.375, in this case we see
that the approximations
one quarter and two quarters
or one half are equally good.
So in this particular
case there are actually two best approximations rather than one.
And we're equally likely to get the outcome one
and the outcome two.
The other two outcomes zero and three, which don't give very good
approximations to theta when we divide by four, actually do appear with some probability
which appears to be just
under 10% in both cases.
So this procedure isn't perfect, but it does provide us with information.
And it's noteworthy that
regardless of theta, we're always guaranteed to draw either the best approximation
or one of the two best approximations when there's a tie, with probability that
appears to be just above 40%.
And the closer that theta
is to the approximation, the higher the probability to see the corresponding value of Y.
And that's a pretty
significant improvement over using a single control Qubit.
This is in fact the phase
estimation procedure when we choose to use two control qubits.
And what we'll do next is to generalize this
procedure in a natural way, where we don't stop with
just two control qubits
but we use however many
control qubits we choose.
And what we'll see is that by
generalizing the procedure, by adding more control qubits, we'll be able to get more and more
accurate approximations of theta. And that will be the general
phase estimation procedure.
In order to generalize the
phase estimation procedure from two control qubits
to however many we choose, we're going to need to understand
how the quantum Fourier transform is defined for other dimensions.
And we're also gonna need to discuss how it can be implemented
with a quantum circuit.
Here's the definition of the
quantum Fourier transform when the dimension is an
arbitrary positive integer N.
Here we're thinking about this operation as being an operation on a system whose classical states are
zero up to N minus one.
And here the matrix that
describes this operation has been expressed using
the direct notation.
We can also describe it in terms of its action
on standard basis states, just to connect it with
what we already saw when N is equal to four.
So here's what it looks
like when N is equal to one, which isn't a very interesting case.
Here it is for N is equal to two, and you'll notice what we get in this case is a Hadamard operation.
Here's the quantum Fourier
transform for N equals three.
For N equals four, which
we've already seen.
And for one last example, here it is when N is equal to eight.
Just like we had before
for the N equals four case, These are the matrices that we associate with the discrete Fourier transform
for each of the dimensions. But we call it the
quantum Fourier transform when we want to think about
it as a quantum operation.
Sometimes by the way, the leading factor of one over the square root of N is not included when we think about the discrete Fourier
transform as a matrix,
but we need that factor here to make sure that we get a unitary matrix.
There's also sometimes a minus sign in each of the exponents, but not always.
It's basically just a personal preference that doesn't change the fundamental
nature of the transform.
But in any case, we'll define the quantum Fourier transform as it's written here on the screen.
There's a very useful shorthand
notation that's common and we'll make use of it
a bit later in the lesson.
And that is to define a
complex number omega N, like we have here.
Specifically as e to the two pi I over N, which can also be written
using signs and cosines
as we have right here. Sometimes we call this
number an N through of unity because when we raise it
to the power N, we get one.
Here's a figure that shows a few examples.
Omega one is equal to one, omega two is equal to negative one, and omega four is equal to I.
In general to get omega N, we can imagine slicing up the unit circle into N equal size pieces like it's a pizza being shared by N people
and omega N is at the
corner of the first piece, assuming that the other corner
of that piece is at one.
So in particular as N
gets larger and larger, the pieces will get smaller and smaller, and omega N will get
closer and closer to one.
And now if we use that notation we can express the
quantum Fourier transform in a slightly cleaner way.
Sometimes this notation
helps to keep things simple as we will see happening
a bit later in the lesson.
There's an efficient quantum
circuit implementation of the quantum Fourier transform
when N is a power of two,
which we'll now take a look at. Although we tend define the
quantum Fourier transform for any dimension N,
we're only gonna need it
in the case that N is a power of two, in order to generalize the
phase estimation procedure.
The implementation will make
use of controlled phase gauge which are depicted as we
have here on the screen.
They look like two
controls connected together along with a number which
is alpha in this case.
And the action of this gate is described by the matrix that's shown here.
These are literally
controlled phase gates, meaning that we have a control Qubit that controls a phase gate.
We saw phase gates way back in lesson one.
But for phase gates specifically, it doesn't actually matter
which Qubit is the control and which is the target.
And we saw that in lesson two, for the specific case of a Z gate.
And now that we have that notion, we can move on to how the
quantum Fourier transform can be implemented.
The implementation is recursive in nature and perhaps the easiest way
to describe it in simple terms is to give an example that
can easily be generalized.
Here's how we can do it
when N is equal to 32.
So there are five qubits.
To be clear, we're associating the
standard basis states of these five qubits with the integers between zero and 31 using binary notation.
The first thing we do is to perform the quantum Fourier
transform for N equals 16 to all of the qubits except for
the least significant Qubit,
which is the one on the top. And that's the recursive
part of the construction.
So to implement this operation, we have to follow the same
pattern but with one fewer Qubit.
And in the base case we
have just a single Qubit for which the quantum Fourier transform is just a Hadamard gate.
Once we apply the QFT on all of the qubits except for the top one, we apply a bunch of controlled phase gates using the phases that are
indicated in the diagram.
We then apply a Hadamard
gate to the top Qubit, and shuffle the qubits around a little bit using some swap gates.
These swap gates have the effect of cyclically permuting the qubits which is needed to make
the construction work.
We can follow exactly the same pattern for other choices of N
provided they're powers of two, where we always start the
controlled phase gates
with alpha being pi over
two for the bottom Qubit and dividing by two each time
moving left in the diagram
to get the subsequent phases. Now it's not at all obvious
that this construction works.
And I'm not gonna explain
why it works in this video.
If you're interested in seeing
the details for why it works, you can find them in the
written content for the lesson.
I will say however that
what's being exploited here is the basic structure of
discrete Fourier transforms
and in fact it's exactly
the same structure that allows the fast
Fourier transform to work.
Another way to say this is that if we look at the fast Fourier transform, we can think about it in
terms of quantum circuits.
And this is the circuit that we get.
So how many gates do we need in total for this implementation?
To figure that out, let's let SM be the number of gates that
we need when we have M qubits.
When M is equal to one, we just need a single gate because the QFT is just a Hadamard operation in this case.
If M is at least two, then these
are the gates that we need.
First we need SM minus one gates for the quantum Fourier
transform on M minus one qubits, whatever that number happens to be.
We also need M minus one
controlled phase gates, M minus one swap gates,
and one additional Hadamard gate.
So here's an expression
of SM in both cases when M is equal to one and
when M is at least two.
This is an example of what's called a recurrence relation and
they show up very commonly in the analysis of algorithms.
This particular one
happens to be very simple and it has a so-called
closed form expression, which we can obtain by summing.
To be precise, the value of SM is the sum of the first M
consecutive odd integers, which equals M squared,
as you may have either encountered before or maybe you just noticed that
at some point in your life.
And it happens to be pretty easy to prove this formula is true by induction on M in
case you're interested in a formal proof.
So that's it. We can implement the
quantum Fourier transform on M qubits using M squared gates.
Just a couple of very
quick additional remarks.
First we don't actually
need all of the swap gates that I've described.
It is possible to effectively
push them all out to the end as long as we adjust which qubits the controlled phase gates
act on appropriately.
And if we do that we'll only
need M over two swap gates in total rounding down.
We'll still have a quadratic cost, but the number of gates can be reduced in this way nevertheless.
And one final remark is that we can actually make the cost even less if we're willing to settle for
a pretty good approximation.
For example, when M gets large, a lot of the controlled phase gates are pretty close to
the identity operation,
and eliminating the
ones that are very close can save us quite a lot on gates while still giving us a
pretty good approximation.
It is also possible to approximate the quantum Fourier transform
with very shallow circuits, meaning ones with small depth, in case that's something
that we wish to do.
And now that we know what the
quantum Fourier transform is for different dimensions, as well as how it can be implemented w hen the dimension is a power of two,
we can go back to the
phase estimation procedure and see how it can be generalized where we use some arbitrary
number M of control qubits.
Here's what the procedure looks like as a quantum circuit for
an arbitrary choice of M.
We have M control qubits on top, which we assume are all
initialized to the zero state.
We apply a Hadamard
gate to each one of them and then each of them is
used as a control Qubit to apply some power of
the unitary operation U,
where we double the number
of times U is applied for each control Qubit.
Here in this diagram I've indicated this by including the powers
on U inside of the boxes rather than showing the controlled U gate
being applied that many times, as a way of both making
the diagram more clear and saving on space so
that it fits on the screen.
Now the first thing that we need to notice
about this procedure is that it might become very expensive.
In particular we're
doubling the number of times each U operation gets applied
for each control Qubit.
And if the way that we do this is simply to iterate a controlled U gate however many times we need,
we're going to get a huge circuit. It'll be exponentially
large in the number M.
That's a major limitation in general, and in particular it limits our ability to get precise approximations
of eigenvalues.
In the specific case of factoring though, which we'll get to shortly, it turns out that we're very fortunate and we can play a trick that allows us
to avoid this exponential blow up in cost.
But in general for arbitrary
unitary operations U, this won't be possible and
we'll pay a steep price
for increasing the
number of control qubits.
I'm not going to go
through a detailed analysis of the circuit in this video and instead I'll just mention that there is a fairly simple
expression for the state
just prior to the measurements which is shown here on the screen.
From that state we can get an expression for the probabilities
of the various outcomes, and it happens to look like this.
And once we have this expression,
we can reason about it, and really this expression
is all we need to carry on.
Like I said, I'm not gonna get into
the details in this video, but you can find them in the
written content for the lesson and it turns out that it's
actually not that complicated,
so check it out if you're so inclined. If we do go through the analysis, what we find is that the situation
is not all that different
from the M equals two case, except that we get more precision.
In particular, we can think
first about the probability to get the very best or one of
the two best approximations,
which we can express like we have here.
You can ignore this subscript of a one on the absolute value if you like.
This is just a symbol that we
can use to remind ourselves that we're talking about
approximations on the circle where we think about theta equals zero
and theta equals one as being the same. The point here is that
we're thinking about whatever choice of Y makes Y over two to the power M
as close as possible to theta.
And once again, just like we
had for the M equals two case, we're guaranteed to get this outcome Y with probability at least 40%.
In fact, the probability is
at least four over pi squared, which is a little bit more than 40%.
10 is not a bad
approximation to pi squared when you're in a hurry.
And that's actually pretty remarkable. What we're talking about is getting the very best
approximation to theta as a fraction Y over two to the power M
where Y is an integer. And we're getting the
very best approximation with probability greater than 40%.
We can also think about
approximations that are worse.
Specifically let's imagine
that Y isn't quite so good, and more specifically let's suppose
that there's a better
approximation to theta of the same form that lies between theta and Y over two to the M,
which can be expressed as
is written on the screen.
In such a case the
probability to get this Y will be relatively small, at most 25%.
It'll actually be lower than that, but 25% is what we get from
a pretty simple analysis, but it's good enough.
As an example. Here's the plot we get when we use three control
qubits rather than two.
This time I'm only
plotting the probabilities for the outcomes three, four, and five because I don't want the
figure to be too messy.
When theta is equal to
one half for instance, we're guaranteed to get the outcome four.
And so we take our
approximation to be four eighths or one half because two to
the power three is eight.
And in this case we're exactly right. And as long as theta is closer to one half than it is to say three
eighths for instance,
we get the outcome four with a probability higher
than the outcome three.
And with probability,
again larger than 40%.
Here's the plot when M is equal to four. And the curves actually
look pretty much identical, except that now we've zoomed
in by a factor of two.
So now the outcomes that are plotted include seven, eight, and nine and we're taking the approximation to be one of these numbers
divided by 16 rather than eight.
And I'll show one more plot where we increase to M equals five.
And again we're gonna be
zooming in by a factor of two.
And here it is. Once again the curves look
pretty much identical, but we're effectively
doubling our precision.
And as before we obtained the very best approximation to theta, with probability greater than 40%.
That's pretty amazing. But if 40% is not good enough
as a measure of confidence,
what we can do is to run the procedure a small number of times, and
take the mode of the outcomes, meaning the one that
appears most frequently.
And if we do that, we'll be extremely likely to end up with a very good approximation to theta.
Remember by the way that every time we run the
phase estimation procedure we have that the eigenvector
comes out unchanged.
So it is available for us to run the procedure
multiple times like this.
In short, we're gathering
statistics about theta, and the point is that by doing this we can get a very precise
approximation to theta
with very high confidence, and we don't need that many iterations of the procedure to do this.
And that is how the phase
estimation procedure works.
In the last part of the lesson, we'll apply the technique
of phase estimation to the integer factorization problem.
As I mentioned at the start of the video, the way this works is that we consider an intermediate problem known as the order finding problem.
We'll see how we can solve
the order finding problem using phase estimation, and then we'll briefly discuss how solving the order finding problem
allows us to factor integers efficiently.
The second part is completely classical and I'll only summarize the
basic idea in this video.
But let's begin with the
order finding problem.
First, let's get some
handy notation in place.
For every positive integer N, we define ZN to be the integers
zero through N minus one.
So for instance, Z one has a
single element which is zero, Z two has elements zero and one,
z three has elements zero,
one and two, and so on.
So ZN is a set.
But we can also think about
it as more than a set. We can think about arithmetic operations like addition and multiplication on ZN
by defining them modular N.
For example, let's suppose
N is equal to seven.
We have that three and five
are elements of Z seven and if we multiply them together we get 15
which leaves a remainder of
one after dividing by seven.
Sometimes we express this by writing that three times five is
congruent to one module seven, like is written here.
But we can also simply write that three times five equals one.
Of course three times five
isn't normally equal to one, it's equal to 15.
But when it's clear that
we're working in Z seven meaning that multiplication
is defined modular seven,
we can simply write that
three times five equals one.
Now among the elements
of ZN for any positive N, some of them will have
GCD equal to one with N
and some won't. And the elements that do have GCD equal to one with N are special.
and we write ZN star to refer to the set of just these elements.
So for example, here's Z 21 star.
among the elements of Z 21, which there are 21 of course, it turns out that 12 of them have GcD equals of one
with 21 and the rest don't.
In particular anytime that
we have an element of Z 21 that's divisible by either
three or seven, we skip it.
There are various reasons
why this set is special, and one of the reasons is that anytime we have an element of ZN star
and we consider the positive
integer powers of that number, we will always eventually
hit the number one,
where just like before we're talking about multiplication modular N.
the smallest positive integer power that gives us one is called
the order of that element.
For example, think about the element A equals four in Z 21 star.
four times four is 16, which is not equal to one modular of 21, but if we multiply by four one more time,
we get 64, and 64 modular
21 is equal to one.
So the order of four modular 21 is three.
Getting to one like this always happens for all of the elements of ZN star.
And by the way, it never
happens for elements of ZN that aren't in ZN star.
So having GCD equal to
one with N like this is both necessary and
sufficient for this to happen.
And just to finish up the
example of N equals 21, here are the smallest
positive integer powers for which this works for
each element of Z 21 star,
and they can each be checked one by one.
And now we can state the
order finding problem, which is simply to find the order for a given element in ZN star.
To be precise, the input is
two positive integer A and N for which the GCD is equal to one,
and the output is the
smallest positive integer R such that A to the power R is
congruent to one modular N,
or equivalently the
smallest positive integer R for which A to the R is equal to one.
Assuming we're doing arithmetic in ZN.
This is believed to be a
computationally difficult problem, no efficient classical algorithm
is known for solving it.
And as we'll discuss the problem is at least as hard as
integer factorization in the sense that if we have an algorithm for solving order finding,
we would be able to use that algorithm to solve the integer
factorization problem efficiently.
In fact, it goes the other way as well, meaning that if you happen to have an algorithm for factoring, you can use it to solve
the order finding problem.
So the two problems are
in some sense equivalent in terms of their
computational difficulty.
Now we'll see how we can solve
the order finding problem on a quantum computer
using phase estimation.
To make a connection between the problems, let's imagine that we have a system whose classical state set is AN.
For any choice of an element A in ZN star, we'll define an operation
MA like we have here.
In words what MA does is to multiply by A, and here the multiplication is modular N.
And for the remainder of this lesson, you should always think about
expressions inside of cats as being computed modular N,
just so we can keep things simple and we don't have to keep on
writing mod N over and over.
This is a unitary operation, but that's only true
because A is in ZN star.
If the GCD of A and N isn't one, this operation won't be unitary.
Here's an example. If N is equal to 15 and A is equal to two, which is in Z 15 star, then
this is the action of M two.
And if you examine this
example for a few moments, you'll see that what's happening is that the elements of ZN are just getting permuted by this action.
So it's both deterministic and unitary, which is to say that as a matrix, MA is a permutation matrix.
And here's the main idea. The eigenvalues of MA are
very closely connected
with the order of A. And by using phase estimation to approximate these
eigenvalues closely enough
we can determine the order of A. So what exactly are the eigenvectors and the eigenvalues of MA?
Well, we're not going to need all of them, we only need some of them.
Let's start off with an easy example.
Here's an eigenvector of MA, we've named it size zero, and it's given by the
sum of cat one, cat a,
cat A squared, and so on up to cat A to the power R minus one, all divided by the square root of R
to make it a unit vector. Here R is the order of A.
And I'll reserve the
letter R for the order of A for the rest of the lesson.
So whenever you see R, that's the order of A for
whatever A we're talking about.
The eigenvalue associated
with this eigenvector is one.
And we can verify that by
applying MA to this vector to see what we get.
MA multiplies by A, so
we just need to increase each of the exponents by
one and this is what we get.
But the order of A is R, so A to the power R equals one.
And we can make that substitution.
But that's the same vector
that we started with. All we've done is to
shuffle the cuts around but we're taking the sum so
this doesn't change anything.
So MA times psi zero is equal to psi zero.
So it's an eigenvector of
MA with eigenvalue one.
That's a very simple
example of an eigenvector and to identify more of them, let's recall the same notation that we had earlier in the lesson.
Omega R is the complex
number on the unit circle we get by taking E to the
power of two times pi times I
divided by R. Last time we had an N rather than an R, but it still works the same
way for R in place of N.
We need this number because
it's going to be appearing in the other eigenvectors
of MA that we'll identify.
And now that we've recalled that notation, we can observe that this
vector named psi one is also an eigenvector of MA.
It's similar to psi zero, we have exactly the same cats and we're summing them up and
dividing by the square of R.
But this time we have various phases multiplying each of the cats.
Omega R to the negative one for A, omega R to the negative two for A squared, and so on up to omega R to
the power negative R minus one
for A to the power R minus one. So the power of omega R
is always negative one times whatever power of A
appears inside of the cat.
I won't go through it in detail, but it is shown on the screen in case you'd like to re-watch the video and pause as needed.
But if we do the multiplication and we simplify again using the fact that A to the power R is equal to one
as well as the very important fact that omega to the power R is equal to one, what we'll find is that we
again have an eigenvector of MA.
This time as we do the simplification, we'll need to pull out a factor of omega R to see that indeed we have an eogenvector
and that vector of omega R represents the eigenvalue associated with this eigenvector.
So that's a second eigenvector
eigenvalue pair of NA.
We can identify additional eigenvectors using exactly the same reasoning, And in fact, if we simply replace omega R
with omega R to the power J for each J between zero and R minus one, we'll always get an eigenvector,
and the associated eigenvalue will be omega R to the power J.
So this actually includes
psi zero and pis one, which we already saw
as well as R minus two, other eigenvector, eigenvalue pairs.
They all work in basically the same way, and to verify them, we just need to know that A to the power R equals one
as well as omega R to
the power R equals one.
There are other eigenvectors of MA like cat zero for instance, but they aren't going to be useful to us and we don't need to worry about them.
We only need to worry about psi zero through psi R minus one.
Let's focus on psi one for a moment, just to try to understand why it is that we care about these eigenvectors
and what they can tell
us about the order R, which is what we're trying to find.
Supposing that we're given
the eigenvector psi one, we can attempt to learn
R in the following way.
First, we perform phase
estimation on this eigenvector using a quantum circuit that
implements the operation MA.
What we get is an approximation to theta, which is one over R in this case.
And second because we're looking for R and we have an
approximation to one over R, the natural thing to do is
to compute the reciprocal
and to round it off to
the nearest integer. We have to round like this
because R has to be an integer.
But we don't have one of our R exactly, we just have an approximation to it.
But if the approximation is good enough, we'll get R when we round,
which is what we're looking for.
And now the question is how much precision do we need to correctly determine R by computing the reciprocal and rounding?
Or in other words, how accurate does our
approximation need to be to make this all work?
Well, it turns out that we do need a pretty accurate approximation.
For example, we can't
afford to confuse one over R with one over R plus one, or one over R minus one for instance.
In those two fractions, one over R plus one and
one over R minus one are pretty close to one
over R when R is large.
But although we do need a
pretty accurate approximation, we don't need a ridiculously
accurate approximation, and it can be shown that
if our approximation
satisfies the inequality that
we have here on the screen, then rounding off will
give us the right answer.
I won't try to argue that in this video, but it is shown in the written
material for the lesson in case you're interested in the details.
And if that's the accuracy
that we're going for, then it suffices to use a
number of control qubits in the phase estimation procedure
that's equal to two times
the length of N plus one.
Where as we had in the previous lessons, the length of N is the number of bits that we need to express N in binary.
By the way, if we're content
to get the best approximation with probability at least 40% and we don't try to
increase our confidence
like I described earlier, then we don't actually need the plus one.
But in any case, we have that the number
of control qubits we need is linear in the length of N
written as a binary string.
We've seen that if we have
the eigenvector psi one, we can use phase estimation to find R, provided we use enough accuracy.
Unfortunately it's not so easy to get our hands on this eigenvector.
So let's ask a different question.
Suppose we don't have psi one, but rather we have psi
for a random choice of J.
Can we still figure out what R is? Or at the very least can we
figure out something about R?
And the answer is yes, we can figure out something
about R, at least on average.
What we can do is to try
to figure out J over R using a very similar method
to the one that we just saw,
but with a key difference.
First, we'll do exactly the
same thing we did before, which is to run the phase
estimation procedure on the eigenvector psi J.
And what we'll get is an
approximation to J over R, as opposed to one over R,
which is what we had before.
But now we have a small problem, because computing the
reciprocal won't give us R, it will give us R over J.
And by the way, we're not
assuming that we know what J is, we're simply given psi J for a random J,
and we're not told what J is. So what can we do?
Well, it turns out that there's a well-known
classical algorithm that can help us, called the
continued fraction algorithm.
And what this algorithm can do is to take our approximation
Y over two to the M and tell us which fraction U over V,
written in lowest terms, and where U and V are both
integers smaller than N is closest to our approximation.
It's a truly fascinating algorithm, and if you're interested in it, you should definitely check it out.
It's very closely connected to Euclid's algorithm for
computing GCDs in fact.
But I won't say anything
more about it in this video.
The point of this is that if we have a good
approximation to some fraction for which the numerator and
denominator aren't too big,
the algorithm can recover the fraction, and that's what we're doing here.
And now we're left with exactly
the same question as before, which is how much precision do we need?
And it turns out that
exactly the same bound that we had before works in this case.
And so choosing M in exactly
the same way as before works here as well.
Now this isn't necessarily
going to tell us R.
What we'll learn if we use
enough precision, is J over R, but that will be a
fraction in lowest terms.
So we could get unlucky in the sense that this random choice of J could have common factors with R,
and they'll be hidden from us. In the worst case for instance, we could get J equals zero and we will learn absolutely nothing.
But that is literally the only
case where we learn nothing.
In general, we'll at least
get a non-trivial factor of R, and if we're able to draw random samples
and get psi J for different choices of J, we can in fact recover
R with high probability by computing the least common multiple
of all of the denominators
that we observe. And this actually doesn't
require very many samples at all.
The bottom line is that some choices of J will hide factors of R, but random choices of J
won't be able to hide the
factors of R for long.
So that is the idea. It remains to consider the implementation and in particular to figure
out how much it costs.
The essence of the idea, to compute the order of a
given element A and ZN star is to apply the phase estimation procedure
to the operation MA.
Let's figure out what
the cost of doing this is as a function of the length of capital N, which I'll denote by little n.
Here's a circuit for phase estimation. We're going to need little n qubits on the bottom part of the circuit
to encode elements of ZN in binary. So we have N control qubits on top and little n qubits on the bottom,
which is nice because that matches with the names that we
used earlier in the lesson.
In order to count the
number of gates that we need for the entire circuit, let's focus first on the cost of the controlled unitary operations.
If we use the techniques
from the previous lesson, lesson six, we can implement MA using big O of little n squared gates
using efficient classical algorithms for arithmetic modular N.
I'll skip the details in this video, but like several other
things I've talked about, you can read more about it in the written material for the lesson.
It's not enough though
to implement just MA.
We also need to implement MA squared, MA to the fourth power, to
the eighth power, and so on
all the way up to MA to a power that's exponential in M.
And we know we're going to need to take M to be linear in little n
to get enough precision.
This is a big concern,
and I raised it earlier.
If we were to implement powers
of MA by simply iterating MA, we'd be in trouble because all these iterations of MA
would incur exponential cost.
Fortunately, we can play a trick to avoid this blow up in cost.
What we can do is as follows, for each power K that we need.
First, we compute A to
the power K, modular N.
This is the modular exponentiation problem that I mentioned in lesson six.
And it can be solved efficiently. And this is something that we can do with a classical computer.
This computation doesn't
need to be performed by a quantum circuit at all.
So let's let B be the result.
So B is an element of ZN star.
And second, in place of MA to the power K, we just use a circuit for MB.
And that's it. B is just some element of ZN star, So the cost to implement MB
is big O of little n squared.
In a nutshell, what we're doing is exponentating in ZN rather than exponentating
a quantum circuit.
But the actual operation we
get is the same either way. It's just multiplication by A, K times.
This is kind of a miracle in fact. And we wouldn't be able to
solve the order finding problem or effect integers efficiently
with a quantum computer
if it wasn't for this.
And now that we know that each of the controlled
unitary operations, including the powers, can be implemented
at cost big O events squared, we can count the total
number of gates we need.
We have N Hadamard gates, and because M is equal
to big O of little n, the cost is big O of little n.
We have M controlled unitary operations that each have cost big O of N squared.
So the total cost here
is big O of N cubed.
And finally, the quantum Fourier transform has cost big O of n squared.
So the total cost is big O of N cubed.
In particular, we see that even with our
module exponentiation trick, the cost of the controlled
unitary operations dominates.
But nevertheless, the cost
is polynomial in little n.
There are also some classical
computations required, like computing the modular exponentiations and running the continued
fraction algorithm,
but those computations
also have polynomial cost. And in fact, they can be done in big O of N cubed operations as well.
There's only one remaining issue, and that is that we need to get our hands on one of these eigenvectors.
How can we do this?
The solution is actually very simple. We don't run the circuit
on an eigenvector.
We just run it on the state one, meaning the binary
encoding of the number one, which we're thinking
about as an element of ZN.
So let's make that
replacement in the diagram.
The reason this works is because of this equation right here.
The state cat one is in
fact a uniform superposition of the R eigenvectors that
we've been talking about.
And that's not immediately obvious, but if you calculate the
sum, you should get cat one.
And if we run the circuit on this state, the output that we'll get
will be exactly the same as if we'd randomly chosen J
and run the procedure on
the eigenvector psi J.
Again, that's not obvious, but an analysis reveals it to be true.
And finally, that is it. We have an efficient quantum
algorithm for order finding.
There's one very short part
of the lesson remaining and a concerns the relationship between integer factorization
and order finding.
I mentioned that if we can solve the order finding problem efficiently, then we can also factor
integers efficiently.
And I want to very briefly give you the main idea for how this works.
It's completely classical. This part actually has nothing
to do with quantum computing.
Here's a method for finding
a non-trivial factor of a given positive integer N.
And by the way, this method only works when N is an odd number, and it's not a prime
number raised to a power.
Those two cases when N
is even or a prime power can be handled separately.
There are efficient classical methods for both detecting and
handling those two cases.
This method is probabilistic. It might fail, but the
probability of failure will be at most a half,
and we can simply run it
multiple times independently to reduce the probability
of error exponentially fast.
First, we choose A between
two and N minus one at random, uniformly.
Then we compute the GCD of A and N.
And if the GCD happens
to be larger than one, then we've just been incredibly lucky.
The GCD will be a factor of N and we can just output it and stop.
Otherwise, the algorithm continues on and we now know that A is in ZN star.
And now we compute the order of A, which is where we need a quantum computer.
Or maybe we have a different
way to compute the order. The algorithm doesn't really
care where it comes from, but the only way that we know
how to do this efficiently
is with a quantum computer.
If the order of R is even, then we compute the GCD of
A to the power R over two minus one with N.
And if that GCD is larger than one, then again we have a factor of N, so we output it and we stop.
Otherwise the algorithm has failed. And in that case, we
can go back to the start and choose a different A
and hope for a better
outcome the next time around.
And that's it. And by the way, once
we found a factor of N, we can recurs on both that factor
and divide it by that factor until we have a prime factorization of N.
So why should this work?
Well, there are two main points. The first is that because A to the power R is congruent to one modular N,
we have that N divides A
to the power R minus one.
Those two statements
are actually equivalent. This is the definition of mod N that you'll find in number theory books.
Second, if R is even, then this equation that
we have here is true.
This is the well-known formula
for a difference of squares.
In fact, the equation is true for all R, but we need R over two to
be an integer in step four.
And so if we put the two facts together, we see that every prime factor of N must divide one of the two
expressions in parentheses,
because that's the only way
that N can divide the product.
Now, it could be that every
single prime factor of N divides the first
expression in parentheses and not the second, but for our random A,
that's not very likely. And so when we compute
the GCD in step four, we're likely to get the product
of some of the prime
factors of N, but not all.
To analyze this carefully
requires some number theory, but it is pretty basic number theory.
So if you find number
theory to be interesting and you'd like to learn more about it, try working through this analysis.
Working through things like this is an excellent way to learn more, but I will leave that to you.
And that's the end of the lesson. In this lesson, we covered
the phase estimation problem, how we can solve it efficiently
on a quantum computer,
and how we can apply the solution to obtain a polynomial
cost quantum algorithm for integer factorization.
I hope you'll join me for the next lesson, which is on Grover's
quantum searching algorithm.
Goodbye until then.